The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
MAXWELL MANN: I'm
going to tell you
why I think that organization
of your code is the bee's knees.
It's the coolest thing ever.
If you organize your
code well, then you
can end up having not
a horrible player.
I think lecture three robot
release is kind of long.
I released some
code, and it's long.
Look at all that stuff.
It's especially large when
you want have 16 point font so
that everybody can see
from back at the end.
But it's just too
much, so here I'm
going to propose that you
organize your code into, as you
can see here on the left,
many separate files.
So this is-- I think
it's [? Hitav's ?] code.
He's one of the devs
this year, and you
can see here his robot player.
He's got the package name,
and he imports some things,
and right after that, he defines
these new types, like base
player, headquarters
player, soldier player,
and encampment player.
And each of these things
is part of base player.
You can see here base player
is this public, abstract class
that he defines here.
And it has certain things
he wants to use later.
And then later when
he has other players,
like an encampment
player, he can just
say, OK, I am going to call
this public class encampment
player extends base player.
And now, this guy has access
to all of this guy's method.
And it's also located in
his own convenient place.
So I'm going to post
some example that
shows how to get your code
separated in a convenient way
if you haven't done that before.
So you've got your
code separated,
and you want to make life easy.
You don't want to
code in a way that's
going to make it hard for you to
make changes and make updates.
Steven Arcangeli,
who won Battlecode
two or three years ago,
has posted on his blog
a description of coding
best practices that
enabled him to really
do well in Battlecode.
He did things like
make sure that things
are in separate files,
that they have subpackages.
And that he worked on
this framework code
most of the time.
He wasn't trying to just
mash out a strategy.
He was building systems
that he could reuse and use
multiple times.
He also made a rapid
iteration system
so he could test his code
against other ways of running
the same code.
And today, Aaron is
here with me to set up
a system for trading
code between us
so we can work more efficiently.
So according to Stephen,
he was doing strategy only
in the last week
of the competition.
The rest of the time, he
was basically just writing
navigation code, or
something very basic,
and then he would sort of
figure out the strategy
after watching the tournaments,
like the sprint tournament
and the seeding tournament.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK,
just steal the strategy
instead of writing it yourself.
Awesome.
MAXWELL MANN: Yeah, I guess
that's one way to do it.
So I'm going to go ahead
and switch on over to Aaron,
and he's going to show
how he would set things up
to start sending me files
in the most efficient way.
AARON EPSTEIN: Hello, I'm Aaron,
the less effective lecturer,
and I'm going to tell you that
the most efficient way to share
files between me and Max is Git.
Spoiler alert, it's Git.
So I have my directory,
it's called user test,
but it's a Battlecode
installation, the same as you
guys have.
I have some stuff in here
that I want to share with Max,
particularly something
in the team's directory.
This awesome player--
awesomer player-- and I
want Max to have it.
So how do I get it to him?
So first, I made a
Bitbucket account.
It's free, it's
similar to GitHub,
except the problem with GitHub
is if you want a private repo,
you'd have to pay for it.
So you'd probably
abusing a public repo,
which means anybody who can
guess your user name just
has access to all
your robots, which
makes it even easier for them
to your code and strategies.
It's kind of silly.
Bitbucket gives you a private
repo with up to five users.
We only give you four users,
so a Bitbucket's perfect.
So you make your
Bitbucket account.
And then I want to make a repo
for Max and I to share code.
So I'm going to call
it Battlecode example.
I want it to be private
so that other teams can't
steal our stuff.
It's going to be
Git, because that's I
all that I know how to use.
It's going to be Java.
Now create it.
MAXWELL MANN: So this
repository, Aaron,
is going to be on the
internet, and so we'll really
be able to access
it from anywhere.
It's sort of its own
backup system, isn't it?
AARON EPSTEIN: Yep.
It's backup, it's
version intelligent,
cross platform, et cetera.
It's perfect.
MAXWELL MANN: Yeah.
Yesterday or the day
before, my computer
gave me a bunch of
Blue Screens of Death.
I think one of my memory
sectors is failing or something.
But I wasn't that nervous,
because we have everything
stored online.
True story.
AARON EPSTEIN: Alright.
So Bitbucket goes ahead and
gives me the instructions.
So I'm basically just going
to follow these instructions.
I've already made the directory
and I'm already in it,
so I don't need to do this.
So right now the
installation's not a Git repo.
So I'm going to go
ahead and make it one.
Get in it, now it's empty.
And then it tells me to
add this thing as remote.
I'll do that later.
OK, so right now it's
an empty Git repository.
It's not very useful,
because it's empty.
If I use Git status, it tells
me that it's basically empty.
Yeah, it tells me that
there's all these things that
are untracked.
It's not tracking anything.
And there's nothing in it.
AUDIENCE: What does it mean when
they're tracked or untracked
By Git?
AARON EPSTEIN: So it said
when I initialized it here
that it was empty.
So even though there's a bunch
of things in this folder,
Git doesn't really know
or care about them yet,
because I haven't told
them where they are,
or what it should
pay attention to
and what it shouldn't
pay attention to,
so it's just empty.
That's why it's labeled
"everything untracked",
because they're not yet tracked.
So let me make some of
these things tracked.
And by some, I mean only
the awesomer player,
because that's the only thing
I want to give Max right now.
So I'm going to do Git add,
because I want to add it
to the list of things
that's tracked.
And go team/awesomer
player/robot.
OK, cool.
Now it's added.
So now if I look at the
status, I have one new file.
I didn't make it, so
it's not new with respect
to the hard drive, but
it's new with respect
to Git, because Git didn't
know about it before.
And then these are
still on track.
So now to share it with Max,
I have to commit this change.
Right now, it's just
been added, but it's
sort of floating
around in space.
So "commit" really solidifies
it into a block of changes
that I can give to max.
So "initial commit",
just because that's
the best practices name
for the first commit.
MAXWELL MANN: You see here
he's put a message with it,
so that when we look
at the commit logs,
we'll be able to see
his descriptions of what
went on for all the changes, all
the way back to the beginning.
And we'll have all
these things posted
in the handy-dandy guide--
gosh, I said it again--
so you don't have to
worry about memorizing it.
Right now you just want to
get the overview of how we're
doing it, and how many
millions of times more awesome
it is to do it this way,
than to email to one another.
AARON EPSTEIN: I should
mention hyphen a means "all",
like for everything, and
m means give a message
here with strings
rather than having
to type it into an editor.
On Windows, if you
leave out the m switch,
you get notepad, which is
not that big of a deal,
because it's just notepad.
Just type it in and hit
Save, and it's okay,
and you remember to use
the m switch next time.
But on Linux, if you forget
the m switch, most likely
it'll give you Vim, which is so
complicated and arcane that it
took me many times before I
even knew how to close it.
MAXWELL MANN: It's like
escape:wq or something.
It's absolutely crazy.
AARON EPSTEIN: I think I've
gathered that colon q quits it,
and colon w saves.
MAXWELL MANN: I think
you have to push
s to start typing again.
It doesn't even let
you put commands in.
AARON EPSTEIN: You
want to say out
of Vim if you're not initiated.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AARON EPSTEIN: OK.
Got it.
Well I just the m switch
so I can stay out of Vim,
because it's only
for the initiated.
MAXWELL MANN: I
see one question.
AUDIENCE: So do you
guys recommend only
sharing specific
files at a time,
instead of the entire project?
AARON EPSTEIN: Yes,
and I will discuss
that eventually, but for now the
only things you want to share
are things that you wrote
yourself and are changing
yourself.
But I will discuss more
of that in the future.
So right now I just want to
share that one specific file.
So now it's committed.
I need to get onto
here, so I do this thing
that it tells me to do.
Basically I'm going
to add as a remote,
like a thing that's not here.
It's a remote, it's somewhere
else, so the server.
I'm going to add one called
"origin", because origin
is the canonical name
for this sort of thing,
and then I follow the URL.
MAXWELL MANN: You can't
copy and paste into that?
AARON EPSTEIN: No.
MAXWELL MANN: Oh, you can't?
MAXWELL MANN: Oh, mine's better.
Right now, he's using MinGW
shell to type these commands.
If you just put it in
Windows command prompt,
I don't think it would work.
I'm going to use to Git
Bash, which you can get--
AARON EPSTEIN: No,
you're using Git Shell,
which opens Windows PowerShell.
MAXWELL MANN: And you
can get that online just
by Google searching it.
AARON EPSTEIN: Cool,
well there you go.
That's how you remove remotes.
Two birds, one stone.
MAXWELL MANN: That's
pretty useful.
We did that on purpose.
That guy's a plant.
I'll pay you after lecture.
AARON EPSTEIN: So to check what
I have, I do the hyphen v. You
might be familiar with
a verbose, hyphen v.
So I have this, it
looks spelled correctly.
Cool.
Now I push to it, like take
my changes and push them,
to "origin", which is the
name I've given to this URL.
"Master" is the master branch.
It's going to ask
me for my password,
because I haven't
configured SSH correctly,
but Bitbucket has
instructions for setting this
up so that your computers
recognize each other.
You don't need to type in
the password every time.
I just haven't done it yet.
OK, now it looks
like I successfully
wrote things to the server.
So Max should be
able to get them.
Oh, no, he shouldn't be able
to, because my repo is private,
and nobody's allowed
to access it but me.
Let me change that.
Settings, access management.
MAXWELL MANN: So I'm M4X Mann.
AARON EPSTEIN: And I want
to give him read and write,
but I don't trust
him to administer it.
MAXWELL MANN: It's a good idea.
I have a certain
tendency of screwing up
certain administration
jobs, this one not included.
So I'm going to go ahead
and switch on over to Me.
Now I'm me.
I wasn't before, but I am now.
Let's make some space here.
On the left, this
is where I have
Battlecode installed,
on the desktop.
And I guess what I want to do
is I want to make this existing
Battlecode directory the
main directory for the root
for my Github version of
the thing that he has.
Yeah, that's the technical term.
So I'm going to go into it.
So now I'm in this directory.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to initialize GIt
so that now it knows that
I'm interested in using
Git in this folder.
And now that I'm in it,
I will do Git remote add.
And I'll go onto
this website, I'm
just going to hit refresh here.
Is this it,
"Battlecode-example"?
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah.
MAXWELL MANN: OK, so you
named it the same thing
as you named the previous one?
AARON EPSTEIN: Yep.
MAXWELL MANN: OK.
So I'm in here.
And I can just right
click and hit Paste
because I have PowerShell.
So now I've now I've added it.
And so I'll then follow
that up with a "git pull" .
And that's going to give me--
oh, it says it's not my--
I need a name?
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah.
You didn't name it.
Yeah, you just did Git remote
add, and you just put the URL.
MAXWELL MANN: OK,
I'll name it origin.
AARON EPSTEIN: No,
the other way around.
MAXWELL MANN: OK.
So I'll name it--
what do I name it?
AARON EPSTEIN: Origin,
and then the URL.
MAXWELL MANN: Add origin,
and then and then the URL.
We'll have this all
written down so you
have the instructions in
front of you when you do it.
AARON EPSTEIN: Now you
should be able to pull.
MAXWELL MANN: OK so
now I can Git pull.
And this should get me the
stuff he wanted to give me.
Now it may end up
being a problem--
AARON EPSTEIN: No, you've
got to specifically
from origin master.
MAXWELL MANN: Ah, git
pull, origin master.
Yeah.
For those of you who
know Git already,
I think it may be giving you
trouble because I may already
have awesomer player.
so we're going to pretend
that I don't have it.
Yeah, so let's go let's
go back to Eclipse.
Oh, it's black.
What is that?
I think Eclipse.
is very unhappy.
Have you ever had this?
OK, where's the package--
AARON EPSTEIN:
There are Windows,
so we should probably just
restart both computers.
MAXWELL MANN: Restart
both computers?
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah, and every
Windows computer in the room.
MAXWELL MANN: Oh, right.
Now let's see, which
is the button that
gets me the package?
Package inspector window?
Open perspective?
Show view, OK.
I've got.
Hey look, it's not dead.
So let's refresh it
and now it's updating.
You see it hasn't got
awesomer player there,
so that when I do this.
Yeah, that wrapped around.
But now I've done this,
if I push that F5,
is that going to-- No?
Did it not work?
It says here,
already up to date.
I think we broke it.
What are we gonna do, Aaron?
AARON EPSTEIN: I don't know.
I don't know what happened.
So you don't have awesomer?
Do you have awesomer?
MAXWELL MANN: I
may have awesomer
without knowing I have awesomer.
I'm that awesome.
Nope, there's nothing in there.
Should we kill everything
and start over?
AARON EPSTEIN: Yep.
MAXWELL MANN: Right.
Doing it the right way.
You saw it here first.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK, so
Bitbucket tells me--
MAXWELL MANN: OK,
I've got an idea.
Make a new package
and send that one.
Something else.
Something different.
OK, let's go back
to Aaron's computer.
So you made a a super thing?
AARON EPSTEIN: A
super awesome player.
MAXWELL MANN: A
Oh my goodness.
So now you're pushing
that onto the master,
and then once that's done, I'm
going to go back to me, right?
OK.
SO I'm going back to
my Battlecode folder.
OK.
And now it's already
got Git in it.
I'm already good to go.
I've set up the remote by
doing Git, remote, add,
origin and then
the HTTPS URL that
was available on the
Bitbucket website.
AARON EPSTEIN: Well, why
don't you Git status.
Just to check.
MAXWELL MANN: I like that idea.
OK, so I deleted a thing.
Maybe if I just push the fact
that I deleted that thing.
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah,
maybe that was a bad idea.
MAXWELL MANN: Well
in any case, we're
going to see what happens.
Maybe if I add, so that
it's tracking the thing that
isn't there, then
that'll improve matters.
AARON EPSTEIN: Let me
just make the reaper.
Oh no, but then you'd have
to type in the URL again.
MAXWELL MANN: Yeah, I could just
paste, but let's do Git pull.
And let's see if
it works, shall we?
AARON EPSTEIN: Nothing to lose.
MAXWELL MANN: Only our dignity.
AARON EPSTEIN: I'm going to
pull from the origin master
specifically.
MAXWELL MANN: Well, what happens
if I just do it as it is?
It's no good?
AARON EPSTEIN: You've
got to configure it
before you do that.
MAXWELL MANN: It said,
unpacking objects.
I think it did things.
AARON EPSTEIN: Well it
unpacked a bunch of objects,
but it didn't know where
to put them, I think.
MAXWELL MANN: It didn't
know where to put them.
Well, I put them somewhere now.
It says, one file changed.
It's fussy?
I'm fussy.
We work together.
OK.
Now the thing is there.
And if we wait 10 minutes,
Eclipse will start.
But while I'm doing
that, you could
talk about the next thing.
Yay, there it is.
Super awesome.
Yeah, that's pretty cool.
AARON EPSTEIN: You
should watch it.
It's super good.
MAXWELL MANN: I
should to watch it?
Is it the same as the other one?
AARON EPSTEIN: No, it's mine.
It's my special one.
MAXWELL MANN: Oh,
it's your special one?
Oh my goodness, you guys
are in for real treat.
Aaron is a coding
beast, I gotta tell you.
This is the representation of
his might and his capability,
right here.
Super awesome is the
red fellow and there he
is, going, capturing
things, defusing mines.
[LAUGHTER]
AARON EPSTEIN: Oh,
it didn't work.
Oh well.
MAXWELL MANN: Sorry, Aaron.
Next time.
AARON EPSTEIN: It's
just a small map.
So you could rush, strategy,
rush OP, et cetera.
MAXWELL MANN: I'll
tell you what,
we'll change the game specs.
We'll change the game engine.
AARON EPSTEIN: I've
already done it.
MAXWELL MANN: Oh, OK.
That makes sense.
I just didn't get
the latest version.
The "Aaron wins all
matches" version.
AARON EPSTEIN: Yep.
OK, anyway-- What?
AUDIENCE: Why don't you change
your team name to Aaron?
AARON EPSTEIN: From what?
What do you mean?
Sorry, I don't understand.
MAXWELL MANN: It's OK.
It's got to do with corruption.
I'll teach you sometime.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK.
Yeah, I don't know
anything about, of course.
So I did Git status, which
is always a good thing to do.
Between every command
that you execute,
that you ask Git to do,
before you should do a status,
and after you
should do a status.
Which means that since I wanted
to execute status to show you,
I should have done Git
status three times.
One before the Git
status, one to execute
the Git status, and one after.
Just so that you get
a really good feeling
for what the status is.
And you should actually
read it a bunch of times.
So Git status, that's
the command I type.
On branch master,
master's a branch.
Got it.
MAXWELL MANN: We'll do
branches in the lab.
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah.
Untracked files.
OK, that's a lot
of untracked files.
Nothing added to commit,
but untracked files present.
OK, nothing added to commit,
means I haven't done anything.
But there's untracked files.
That's bad.
When I tell you status is
really important, I mean it.
But if all this red stuff comes
up every time you type status,
you're going to start not
paying attention to it.
So an important thing
to do is to tell
Git to ignore these things
that I never want to add.
So I just want
them to be ignored.
So what I do is I open up my
favorite text editor eMags,
and I go to
directory, and I make
a file called dot Git ignore.
And I no longer exist.
OK.
Oh man, eMags is too
clever sometimes.
MAXWELL MANN: Because he made
this file before the lecture
in preparation, and
then deleted it.
But eMags was like,
are you sure you
didn't want to not have
the things you deleted
and then looked for later
in a different place?
And then he said, yes.
AARON EPSTEIN: Now it's empty.
OK, cool.
So I have this empty
file, and to make it
ignore this dot installation
information, which I'm never
going to add to the
repo, I just type
in dot installation information.
And then to make it
ignore everything
in the doc folder,
because I'm never
going to have to share that
with Max, because he has
from the installer,
do doc slash star,
and then version
dot text, et cetera.
Or I get this handy-dandy one
that I've already written,
and just copy all of it.
Yeah.
So now that I've made the
dot Git ignore and saved it,
now the only untracked
things are the other teams.
So I could
specifically add those.
Teams slash example,
teams slash macro player,
team slash suicide player.
MAXWELL MANN: Yet another
one of his classics.
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah, right.
Save that, Git status.
The thing with the squiggly
is just another eMags Folder.
I'll just ignore everything
that ends in squiggles.
Cool, so now the only
thing that's untracked
is a dot Git ignore.
So I'll just add
the dot Git ignore.
Because I do want to share
that with Max so he doesn't
to go through all that
trouble I just went through.
Now if I do status I get
this really nice-- oh, no.
Now to commit the fact that
I've added the Git ignore.
I do the AM switch again.
A for everything in the index.
And m for not bringing up
VIM and pulling my hair out.
Make a nice commit message so
Max knows what this file's for.
OK, now if I do status I get
this really clean status.
It even says that my working
directory's clean, nothing
to commit.
Perfect.
So I'll push that to Max and
he can get it, if he wants.
Type my password again, 123ABCD.
MAXWELL MANN: So I noticed that
we untracked a bunch of things
because we didn't
want to include them.
But I was saying before this
that it might be convenient
for us to just share
the whole of everything.
Why wouldn't we do that?
AARON EPSTEIN: OK, there's a
lot of reasons not to do it.
A couple things you don't
want in your Git repo.
Anything that's
platform specific,
probably you don't
want in your Git repo.
So right now I'm using Windows
and Max is using Windows,
but Steven doesn't use Windows.
So anything that's
on our team-- if I
have a path that
is something like C
backslash users, that's going to
look like nonsense once Stephen
checks it out.
So anything platform specific
doesn't go in the repo.
Another thing you
don't want in the repo
is stuff that we distribute.
By we, I mean we as
Battlecode people,
not we as in this
false Battlecode
team that has the repo.
So we as Battlecode people
release an installer
that gives you things like
example [? flux ?] player,
and documents, and
stuff like that.
You don't want those in
the repo because, let's say
I add example [? flux ?]
player to the repo.
I check it in-- now, this
is I as in this guy--
I check in example
[? flux ?] player.
Max is working on really
complex navigation code.
I have version 1.3, and
Max has version 1.0.
An example [? flux ?] player,
the one I just checked in,
makes a 1.3 specific
function call
that breaks if
you use it in 1.0.
So I check it in, I upload it.
Max downloads my code expecting
to get some more navigation
stuff that he really needs.
But he also gets this new
version of example [? flux ?]
player that makes a 1.3
specific function call,
and now his code
won't compile at all.
And now he has to
interrupt the workflow
that he was really
deep into navigation,
and isolate where is
this red X coming from,
and find out that it's because
it was in a different version.
Then he has to go download
it from Battlecode.org,
and then install it again,
and then update, and then
find that the update doesn't
work on his computer.
Then he has to fix that.
All of this, and then in the
process, forgetting everything
he knew about navigation.
So when he gets back
to, he's already forgot.
It's just a pain.
So anything that we update,
just get it from the installer.
Don't put in the repo.
There's no need.
Anything binary, don't
put that in the repo,
because it's inefficient.
Git has really good algorithms
for compressing and storing
only meaningful
things about text,
so if there's a huge
one megabyte text file
and I change one line,
Git stores one line.
None of those algorithms that
it has applied to binaries.
So if I upload a binary, and I
change one line in a binary--
a binary meaning a zip
archive or a picture.
If I change one
pixel in the image,
Git just has to
store both copies
of the image, which
is inefficient.
So if you store our
whole installer,
it's like 30 megabytes.
Every time we update, you'll
add another 30 megabytes.
So instead of this 500 kilobyte
repo that Max and I have right
now, if you kept going like
30 megabytes per installer,
you'd end up with 500 megabytes.
Bad.
Not good.
And then, anything
that's personal,
like project settings
you don't need them.
So what do you put in the repo?
Text documents that
you've created,
like source code, or new maps
that you want, or a script.
Or all the incredible
documentation
that you're going to have
for your players, all
of that, that can
go in the repo.
Cool.
MAXWELL MANN: In
some past years,
we've offered another
one of these side
prizes for best documented code.
Are we going to be doing
that this year, Stephen?
Think a best documented
code side prize this year?
AUDIENCE: Probably
MAXWELL MANN: Probably.
Something to keep in mind.
Keep those forward
slashes on your left ring
finger, which is to say, ready.
Do you hit it with
your pinky finger?
AARON EPSTEIN: Mine is
on the left bracket,
because I use Dvorak.
MAXWELL MANN: Right.
But it's still the same finger.
AARON EPSTEIN: No,
it's the pinky.
How do you go all the way over
there with the ring finger?
MAXWELL MANN: I
think I was mistaken.
AARON EPSTEIN: I think--
yes, it is the same finger.
Yeah, pinky.
Pinky active coding.
Cool.
So then we just showed you an
example where I made a repo
and put some files in
it and push to server.
Max made his own repo,
pulled some stuff.
He got it.
He could do the
same thing, where
he can add files and push
it, and I can get them.
And that's great.
But now we have to show you what
happens if Max and I both try
and change one thing,
the same thing.
Then we get a conflict.
It's really scary,
and the reason why--
or, it's a reason that
some people give up on Git.
But we're going to navigate it.
It's going to be OK.
MAXWELL MANN: OK, let's do this.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK, so let's
go to my super awesome player.
I have this number
capturing channel here.
I think it's not big enough.
So I think you should
make it bigger.
MAXWELL MANN: Well, I think
it's not well commented enough.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK,
I'll make it bigger,
but you try and explain it.
Which is silly because you
don't know what it's for.
But I'll make it bigger, because
I think that's important.
It's a radio channel, so
in case you didn't get it,
making it bigger's not
going to change anything.
But anyway, I'll pretend.
MAXWELL MANN: Okay,
I've saved my changes.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK so I
did a status, because I'm
about to execute commit.
So first I did a status.
Yeah, you're getting
the hang of this?
Now I'm going to do a
commit, because modified,
that's what I wanted.
I wanted this player modified.
Do a nice commit.
OK.
I would use an
exclamation mark here,
but no exclamation marks
in Git commit messages
because bash handles
them correctly.
So they can't have
exclamation marks in them.
MAXWELL MANN: Alright, I've
pushed my excellent change.
I hope you learned
something from it.
If I may say so, it's
a wonderful comment.
I think that you really
couldn't expect much better.
AARON EPSTEIN: Alright, I'm also
pushing my change, but wait.
It didn't work.
Why?
Updates were rejected
because the tip of the branch
is behind remote
counterpart pull.
OK, I think what that means
is that because Max pushed
and I tried to push
to the same place,
Git doesn't like
that because then it
wouldn't know which is
mostly recent version.
So it tells to
resolve it by pull.
A lot of commands, when
they give an error,
will tell you what
command to fix it with.
So because I'm
about to do a pull,
first I'm going to do a status.
OK, that's cool.
And I'm going to pull.
123ABCDE.
Oh no.
Conflict.
Look at that, all caps.
Automatic merge
failed, fix conflicts
and commit the result.
So team super awesome robot
player dot java had a conflict.
MAXWELL MANN: So Aaron,
I guess it's up to you
now to fix that conflict.
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah, it is.
So I go to robot
player dot Java.
MAXWELL MANN: Oh man, why don't
you do window preferences,
and change your size
to something non-zero.
AARON EPSTEIN: Aw
man, but I'm so
excited about
fixing the conflict.
I just want to fix
the conflict though.
Is this going to
fix the conflict?
MAXWELL MANN: Appearance.
Some conflicts have been going
on for thousands of years,
I think it can wait.
Yeah, then you go to Java.
And it's only like
another 16 Windows.
Text editor font.
AARON EPSTEIN: This is terrible.
MAXWELL MANN: I know.
I have to do it every lecture.
16 is a good number.
Let's make it bigger, because
you have better resolution.
His computer's a beast.
It's a pretty darn
nice computer.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK cool.
Alright, I've got tons of red.
It didn't work.
OK, so the conflict markers
are as obvious as they can be.
Really big, loud, not part
of any programming language.
Obviously errors that
you want to clean up.
Nice x's.
So what this is, head is the
head of my current stuff,
so that's going to be my copy.
And then this really
long number here
is the hash name
of Max's commit.
So this is Max's thing.
Max made a comment, and
I changed the number.
And so even though I know
that all of my changes
are going to be superior
to anything that Max wrote,
Git doesn't know that.
So since it's conflicted,
it asked me to fix it.
In this case, I'll take what
Max wrote and add it to mine.
And then delete it.
Not the other way
around, by the way.
MAXWELL MANN: Everybody's
got to have standards.
AARON EPSTEIN: Yeah.
Oh, I didn't delete that.
Cool, so now it compiles.
Probably still doesn't
beat the stupid [? rush ?]
player OP stuff.
[INAUDIBLE] It
compiles, and now I
have to tell Git
about the success.
So I do a commit, but before
I do the commit-- yeah?
Getting it yet?
Oh, it deleted awesomer player.
That's what Max did
on his computer.
And we both modified
robot player dot java.
Pointing with my
mouse, remember.
That's cool, but I fixed it.
So, "merge a success.
Cake imminent."
Is that the right spelling?
MAXWELL MANN: It's close.
AARON EPSTEIN: OK.
And then I push that.
MAXWELL MANN: I'm
going to get it.
Git pull origin master.
I'm ready to push this button.
And-- yeah.
Cool,
AARON EPSTEIN: So that's
a conflict resolution,
which happens more
than is pleasant,
but is not too hard to deal
with once you know you're doing.
MAXWELL MANN: If we had edited
different lines of the same
file, there'd be no conflict
because Github is so smart
about which lines were
changed and which weren't.
It would just go ahead
and it would merge those
automatically.
AARON EPSTEIN: Alright, so
before Max takes my changes
and starts messing
around with them,
I'm going to just mention,
but not thoroughly explain,
a bunch of super
useful Git commands.
If this wasn't enough, then if
you go look up these commands
and what they're
for, then you'll
be convinced that
Git is essential.
Git checkout.
Git log.
Let me do this.
If I show you the log, which
is something I forgot to do,
if you do a status before
and after each command,
after you're done with the
second status, do a log.
And log tells you
what's happened.
Pointing with the mouse.
OK, right?
This is the whole
history of what happened.
So Git checkout lets you take
any of these points in time
and set your
repository, like you're
working copy, the copy on
disk, to what was here.
So if I want to go to what
happened before the bigger
numbers commit, I could check
this out, and do Git checkout.
Git branch.
Branches lets you have
parallel workflows.
It's really smooth.
I have this document
that I found
online that describes
a really good, really
useful way of using branches.
I'll discuss in the lab.
Git reset hard.
So, commit is like
a way of saying,
these changes are great.
They're solid.
I like them, keep them.
Anything you
haven't yet commited
can be obliterated
by reset hard.
So you accidentally RMRF
one of your players.
Or you make some change that
actually causes a divide
by zero, and you
have no idea how,
and you've spent half
an hour looking for.
You've just given up and
you just want it gone.
Git reset hard just obliterates
anything that's not committed.
Stash does the same thing,
but puts it somewhere.
And then you can take it
back off with stash pop.
Git k summons a GUI visualizer
of the entire history.
I'll just go ahead
and summon it.
There's our history, there's
some diffs, what was changed.
This was the merge,
how it looks.
Great for visualizing
stuff if you're not,
or even if you are good
at reading the terminal.
Other commands.
Diff shows you the difference
between two commits.
Like if I added comment
to message channel, what?
I don't remember that.
What comment was it?
I could do Git diff between
31d and the thing before it.
Oh, 31d was ambiguous?
One six.
490 was ambiguous.
MAXWELL MANN: Make it E36.
AARON EPSTEIN: Cool.
Oh, that's where I
deleted awesome player.
It looks like you added
awesome player, which
means I probably specified
in the wrong order.
Yeah, so that's a comment.
Cool.
That's diff.
Revert makes the
inverse of a commit,
if you want to get rid of one.
Bisect lets you do a binary
search through your history
to find a bug.
If you find out that
something-- you find out
some cache you wrote three
weeks ago doesn't work anymore.
It worked when you wrote,
but it doesn't work anymore,
but you haven't
worked on it at all.
So it's clearly something
caused by something else.
It doesn't work this commit, it
doesn't work the commit before,
so something you wrote somewhere
in the last three weeks
broke your cache system and
you have no idea where it was.
Git bisect lets you
binary search through
your commit history to pinpoint
the location of the bug.
Look it up, it's too complicated
to be explained in 30 seconds.
But it saved me a
lot of time once,
where I was looking a
bug for like four hours.
I gave up.
Bisect let me find
it in 30 minutes,
and-- you know, programmer time.
I hadn't used bisect, I
really would have just
had to rewrite
sections of the engine.
There was no way I
was going to find it.
It was something really dumb.
Blame does what it sounds like.
So if I do get
blame on-- it tells
me who was responsible
for every line.
And the evidence is clear.
The only person
I can claim blame
for super awesome
players loss is myself.
There's nothing here except me.
It's all me.
If Mad had changed some line,
like this one or whatever,
if it wasn't checking this
encampment thing right,
and it would have said Max man.
And I could have
tracked it down.
But no, it looks like
this file is all me.
It's the only person I
can blame for my defeat.
But anyway, blame.
Blame people.
It's great.
MAXWELL MANN: That's
a pretty good summary.
It seems like you've talked
about quite a lot of functions.
AARON EPSTEIN: No
praising, only blaming.
I actually think there is a less
negative version of blame that
does the same thing,
but use blame.
OK.
MAXWELL MANN: So you've
covered what you need to cover.
We've shown you
examples and things.
We've given you summaries.
I'm sure your mouths
are watering already.
I want to give a
little bit of a demo,
because the sprint tournament
is coming up so soon.
The sprint tournament
submission deadline is Monday.
So this is how you would submit.
So if you haven't
submitted already,
you right click on the
robot you want to submit.
And you go to export.
And I think the instructions
for this online.
Yeah, we're going to
switch to my computer.
My goodness, that
makes a lot of sense.
So here we are, I'm going to
right click on the robot player
that I want to submit.
This is the package.
I export, archive file.
And I have to name it my team.
So I need to actually change
the package name to team,
and then my team
number in three digits.
Otherwise it doesn't work.
And then I'll just export
it to an archive file.
This would export
to the desktop.
And then later I can
go on to battle code,
and I can say, alright,
upload my player.
And I'll be able to choose
the JAR file from the desktop
where I've got it.
And I can give it my own name
and then I can submit it,
and it'll tell me whether
it was compiled and worked
successfully.
So that's a complete
introduction,
an entirely complete
explanation of Git.
Everything you ever needed to
know, except for the things
we're going to go over in lab.
Aaron's shaking his head.
There's a lot to learn, and it
only makes your life easier.
It only helps.
Except when it doesn't.
So with that, the next lecture
is going to be on swarm,
and I'll also cover some
topics in debugging.
So you're going to watch
robots dancing around
in very mellifluous--
is that the right word?
In any case, they're going
to dance in fancy ways.
Fancy pants dance.
And that'll take care of it.
So thank you for
coming to this lecture.
I hope you enjoy the Thai food,
and I'll see you tomorrow.